martin bureau michel si roger luc
ferrandez bonsoir
martin veut nous parlait souvent de ce
qui se dit au caucus de la caq jeu
legault a dit aujourd'hui écoutez j'ai
pas besoin de bons et on imagine que
beaucoup de sondages etc mais j'ai pas
besoin de magie là je sais écouter mes
députés je savais que les gens n'avaient
plus qu'à s'il fallait qu'on arrive avec
un vrai calendrier de déconfinement on
l'écouté
n'oubliez pas aussi que j'ai un caucus
de 74 députés donc une fois par semaine
je les écoute et pisser sur les 14
députés la écouteurs citoyens donc j'ai
bien vu dans les dernières semaines que
la grogne les gens qui étaient des
années le pourcentage qui
met en question les contraintes mais
augmenté encore une fois aux deux lots
de la pression d'abord on l'a tolérée
pendant tout le mois de janvier la
pression à s'arrêter facile en janvier
pour nous autres de dire on loge tout
seul ou mais ça n'a pas été responsable
est ce qu'on attendait c'est d'avoir le
goût comme didot de la santé publique
pour être capable d'avoir un plan de
déconfinement
sur une période d'un mois
je rappelle jusqu'au 14 mars ce plan va
jusqu'au 14 mars et là le vide à peu
près toutes les mesures le 14 et tous
les lundis 14 21 28 3 le 10 février les
matches les congrès les les commerces
pardon il y rassemblement privé plus de
limites à compter de ce samedi alors
martin oui il y avait de la pression de
la gauche à des fins dit si je n'ai pas
fait avancer que je pouvais pas le faire
avant a dit hé bé c'est compliqué en
fait il y avait je voudrais deux choses
un peu le fond qui appelons seule la
forme sur le fond je pense qu'il est
vraiment pas le choix la pression de son
caucus oui mais la pression des
commerçants les manifestations aussi ça
compte
et on voit qu'elles s'accumulent et puis
on est au québec la province où dans le
monde l'endroit où il y avait les
mesures les plus sévères alors on voit
les annonces en saskatchewan maison ils
vont avoir terminé à la saint valentin
nous autres va falloir attendre un mois
de plus alors monsieur legault veut pas
vraiment le choix d'arriver avec quelque
chose d'un peu de prévisibilité
quand je parle de la forme c'est qu'on
sentait quand même une certaine tension
dans ce point de presse l'autre la santé
publique et le gouvernement d'ailleurs
les rôles de chacun est extrêmement bien
campés monsieur legault a pas pris les
questions qui ne lui revenait pas
d'excès la santé publique il se retourne
est là et on s'entête chez le docteur
boileau jodie bauges mise sur un payet
mais les hospitalisations risque
d'augmenter alors on sentait que une des
discussions conduit à ccr il sûr qu
est-ce qu jusqu'où on peut aller le dal
déconfinement oui mais encore une fois
michel c'est luc la pression puis je ne
parle pas que des manifestations mais il
ne s'agit que de parler aux gens autour
de nous il y avait un décrochage et non
il fallait être à peu près au même pas
que dans les autres démocraties de la
planète la même chaîne oui c'est clair
les gens sont fatigués sont année il y
avait une tension qui venait avec ça en
même temps vous savez on peut faire le
plus beau plein de déconfinement mais si
une sixième bague qui arrive quelque
part au mois de mai alors on va tous
confinés j'ai fait c'est pas un plat
absolue ça ne peut pas être un plat
absolue puis il faut quand même pas
oublier il ya encore une cinquantaine de
morts par jour c'est énorme quand on
passe alors oui il ay accepte que
la série médicale actuellement ça
fonctionne mais il y avait beaucoup de
pression au 6e jeu on va parler des
morts après parce que vous ce sujet qui
est difficile mais on attend toujours le
rapport met d'abord tour de table sur ce
qui est annoncé aujourd'hui
mais ça fait longtemps qu'on le sent
venir c'est à dire qu'il ya deux
conditions de base qui sont bien plus
importants que la grotte la première
c'est que les efforts que l'on fait ne
se traduisent pas par une réduction
suffisante des hospitalisations si on
l'avait constaté parce que on fait plus
d'efforts qu'ailleurs on avait plus de
spécialisation qu'ailleurs alors les
commencé d'abord hiatus qu'on avait pas
dans les premières vagues et la deuxième
chose c'est que les gens qui se
retrouvent malade son poste sont pas des
gens qui sont ce sont soit des chants
qui sont pas vaccinés ou déjà comme la
comorbidité donc la moyenne de la
population ne se retrouvent pas au soir
c'est du cinéma me sens bien plus
important pour déterminer du du retrait
du confinement que la grogne de la
population ouais c'est ça pour un jeu
faisait référence marthien michel à le
casser monsieur dubé qui dit j'ai
demandé une étude parce que pour les
décès oui on peut les compter mais ce
n'est pas des décès causés par la coved
dans la plupart des comme celle ci faut
quand même le dire il ya des gens qui
ont la coved qui par ailleurs décès de
cancer de tout sur d'autres maladies
asthme pour ça que la causalité et pas
de direct du b10 j'attends l'étude la
tue le plus président oui mais ce
quelqu'un meurt d'une crise cardiaque et
est porteur du virus de l'aco vide
social de ces maudites lescar dia qui
dira pas qu'on vive mais il a dit il ya
des choses qui avait demandé son
contraire et quand c'est pas clair ceni
dans la colonne kobe
bryant n'a perdu que le compte quand
même au québec la hausse ayant 2 qui
arrive malade et on les diagnostique on
les détecte dont detec dako vide alors
ils deviennent des cocos vide il utilise
d'aidé dicko vide alors que sont pas
entrés comme ça j'ai pour ce qui est de
cette étude là ça fait quand même deux
semaines qu'on l'attend cette étude s
attarde exactement on l'attend très bien
et où joël heit ben non on va l'écouter
lui dis ça suffit
ce jeu politique cette joute politique
contre les non vaccinés reproche à son
premier ministre
son chef de parti d'avoir fait ça depuis
les dernières élections les côtes je
peux pas m'empêcher de constater à
regret que tant le ton que les
politiques de mon gouvernement ont
changé drastiquement à l'aube la
dernière campagne électorale et pendant
la dernière campagne d'une approche
positive et rassembleuse une décision a
été prise d'adopter une approche qui
divise et qui stigmatisent je pense que
cette approche est que cette
politisation de la pandémie risque de
miner la confiance du public envers nos
institutions de santé publique et c'est
pas un risque à prendre à la légère
qu'avez vous pensé de cette sortie
autour de tables nappées de l'udc
je pense que c'est tout le contraire de
ce qu'il dit cette idée de dire que on
voit je veux parler de façon rationnelle
et personnels de sujets ça ne se fait
pas en politique peut pas aller dans un
peut pas aller dans un top chaud puis
dire entre nous de vous faire une
confidence dont tente un micro en
dessous du nez c'est toute la population
qui est mise au courant alors cette idée
de dire c'est simplement et humblement
c'est mon idée personnelle ça n'a aucun
sens en politique c'est une bombe et
d'ailleurs ce sont les conservateurs qui
reprennent l'ensemble de ces deux de ses
arguments aujourd'hui donc il ya un an
parce que toi juste discuter comme
c'était à l'université où c'était à ton
salon tout ce que tu dis on va être
repris par l'adversaire très bien michel
c est ce que ça montre pas ce que lui a
dit à plusieurs reprises je ne suis pas
seul dans le caucus il ya des gens qui
ont un malaise vis-à-vis par exemple la
vaccination obligatoire des employés
fédéraux et mêmes des camionneurs est ce
que ça est-ce que ça rende compte d'un
malaise plus profond
côté les députés monsieur le bois permet
pas au bout de ses députés unsa même
chose que les députés libéraux ils sont
au courant de ce cas population aux fins
et la grogne dont on parlait tout à
l'heure la santé aux autres si ce que ce
qui est étrange et les gens jouent un
coup ce que je faisais c'est que
monsieur la demande mais si ils savent
quelque chose de très réel
la politisation et l'utilisation
politique des vaccins ça a commencé la
campagne électorale pas longtemps après
d'ailleurs le
directeur des communications de monsieur
chrétien dans dobermann leur suggérer de
faire
franchement way et comme par hasard ils
l'ont fait et ils n'ont pas utilisé
normal la question des vaccins qui sont
que ça c'était il ya quatre mois et lui
cinq mois ils étaient où monsieur live
band pendant ce temps alors c'est la vie
ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui n'est quand
même pas feu martin beck ouais c'est mon
député
de ma circonscription
en fait je suis tombé en bas de ma
chaise presque reste très très surprise
de voir surtout que généralement ce
genre d'affaires qu'on voit venir puis
en plus quand on écoute son point de
presse on voit qu'il était extrêmement
bien préparées en français et en anglais
alors ils savent exactement ce qu'ils
disaient c'est avait chaque mot avait
été choisi et pesé alors qu'est-ce qu'il
veut monsieur light bande ku de
notoriété subi pour son avenir ça c'est
pas tellement claire mais c'est la suite
des choses qui vont tu vas nous en dira
plus long mais c'est certain que quand
tu comptes dans ton propre but en
politique qu'il faut que tu aime
beaucoup la solitude parce que ça va
être très dur pour lui son avenir tout
le monde va se rappeler de ses couleurs
très bien monsieur bout mais je pourrais
fait saillir y est le plus dangereux
d'un caucus que député jack 6 ce
qui n'explique pas des savants cela met
donc le contexte est différent l'europe
adore comme michel votre sujet préféré
j'ai fait un bon papier michel bon
papier
je retrouve pas le détail et comment ça
s'appelait le détail je me souvenais
plus de 27 sur le même jeu
jamais des oui j'étais ailleurs
les charges à leur encontre ok je vais
mettre tous les remettre la carte le rem
de l'est c'est un gros projet ces 10
milliards de dollars juste la partie de
l'est n'a pas tous leur m l'autre m
avance mais on n'a pas leur une autre
fois on a beaucoup parlé pour la portion
rené lévesque surélevé est-ce que ça
allait être la hausse
la rtm qui est une agence qui coordonne
le transport en commun à principe dans
la région de montréal dit c'est mal
ficelé c'est mal dessinés et 10 en plus
que vous aviez écrit michel c'est à dire
que l'on voit le suivais mon doigt le ce
qu'on peut retenir en second le rem de
l'ess en turquoise vont longer le métro
mini repas se fondra honoré-beaugrand la
station verte dont quelqu'un qui est de
pointe au temps qui va aller au centre
ville va aller va rester dans le train
il reprend le métro banc et ce à la rtm
dit vous vous dites ou si on veut qu'un
habite kicanas des mois sans viser merci
de des clients métro parce que le rêve
besoin d'être financés bref êtes
d'accord c'est pas un bon projet pour
l'instant écoutez le chiffre le plus
important dans tout ça faire de ses 94
pour ça 94 % des usagers du rêve à
l'heure de pointe bonne cannibaliser
soit du trait de mascouche et pour la
plupart du métro à un moment donné tout
d'un jeu de l'année passée de la rtm
tous les gens qui s'occupent de
transport en commun on dit on n'a pas
besoin d'un autre lié avec le centre
ville d'ailleurs les gens de l'est
souvent ne vont pas s'en trouver une
scission de l'intérieur des quartiers de
l'est oui ou au stade olympique où un
peu plus loin mais je dis c'est alors le
pour que l'om soit rentable pour la
caisse il faut que les gens restent dans
le plus longtemps possible parce que la
subvention et au nomde kilomètre
passager si ce que la reine fait mais il
peut pas faire autrement quand
cannibalisant ce qui est existence que
panda lieu on a une part de plus loin
luc ferrandez
on va voir juste la question plus alors
de pointe aux trembles on aurait beau
grand ya quand même un nouveau tronçon
tronçon qui va être fait important les
gens de l'est ne sont pas desservis que
penser de ce rapport
si le gouvernement avait voulu mettre
fin au projet il y aurait pas agi
autrement c'est à dire que je peux pas
je peux pas imaginer que la rtm qui a eu
aucune fuite du rapport de la rpm faire
les acteurs de cabinet de monsieur
legault ça ne me rend pas dans la tête
mais ce que j'ai vu en politique
municipale c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne première chose et deuxième
chose la réaction immédiate de monsieur
de goût de dire bon baissé à madame
plantes de décider c'est le but de ce
projet là ou pas c'est une façon de lui
mettre sur les épaules la décision
qu'ils soient qui va être impopulaire
dans un sens ou dans l'autre
martias ou est ce que québec finalement
se dit on a d'autres chats à fouetter 10
milliards leur m2 l'oeil s'entend pas
entre eux bye bye en fait ce que le
gouvernement dise si nous on est prêt
mais parce que c'est le projet de
monsieur legault soleure m2 l'instant
s'il fait leur haine de l'ouest si le
projet des libéraux qui en même temps
c'est le projet qui fait l'équilibré
entre le troisième vient montréal québec
il passe d'ailleurs le rem de l'est dans
ces deux circonscriptions le de montréal
baugé et pointe aux trembles pied ce que
dit monsieur legault dbacks t il ya 10
millions sur la table on est prêt à le
financer
arrangez vous vous souffler le chaud et
le froid reflète le projet si vous
voulez le tapis si vous le voulez pas
beaucoup d'eau tant pis on a 1000
milliards sa table tant pis je repose la
question autrement est ce que l'est de
montréal un jour va finir par avoir un
projet le mot à la mode structure un
vrai projet de transport en commun parce
que l'air tm prend des chefs de 2013 des
gens qui voyagent hors projet ce n'est
pas pour l'avenir ce n'est pas pour 2030
un lieu qu'on le fait oui bien sûr et
surtout un rien parce que dans leur ai
mis une portion immobilière censée y
avoir beaucoup de projets mobilier qui
vont se construire le long des stations
et qui vont apporter du monde mais les
calculs font que si t'as pas une base de
personnes qui se rencontrent au
quotidien au centre-ville important les
ajouts sont pas suffisants pour faire
vivre le projet et là on parle et on
parlait de 2000 seulement personne qui
partiraient qui prendrait plus leur
voiture qui utiliserait le rêve et on ne
sait pas combien il va y avoir de
nouvelles résidences qui vont se
construire de nouveaux immeubles vont se
construire mais c'est sur une période de
20 ans est ce que monsieur de gouvets
vraiment dans une élection que sa vie
dans quelques mois mettre sa tête sur le
billot pour une amélioration de la
situation dans 20 états je pense que
c'est le match tel un sérieux bond celle
ci y en aura jamais de transport dans
l'est non ils voient la solution la
solution c'est de ne pas aller plus loin
que honoré beaugrand qui le terminus de
jouer trimestre de s'en aller par la
boisson vers l'est mais la ligne b du
métro est parfaite pas pour que gmail et
les postures ici dans cette partie qui
s'étendra puis vous arrêter à
l'assomption assomption pinard et bogota
ils ont allégé j'ai jamais compris
pourquoi d'ailleurs mais c'est la chose
la plus cette affaire ça va on doit
faire plus de choses dans l'est avec sa
queue avec là avec les roms qui coûte
très cher en construction il faut quand
même le dire quand une offre pour sûr de
rien du tout j'ai ma portion n'a rien
d'une portion toute la portion qui vont
centre-ville et du dédoublement
c'est ce qui l'avait été après honorer
vos regrets c'est du dédoublement et on
en a pas besoin
est ce que fait permet d'ajouter quelque
chose ou dans le rapport on dit aussi
que ça me coûtait 81 18 millions
supplémentaires par année aux
municipalités et 150 millions
supplémentaires par année au
gouvernement ça aussi ça fait réfléchir
alors si on fait juste enlever des
personnes de de la stm et du train de
l'est pour les mettre dans le rêve et
que ça nous coûte 150 millions + 100
millions par année en plus de 10
milliards c'est juste ça n'a aucun bon
sens
s'est passé votre vie à dire il faut
plus d'accès multiplier transports en
commun qu'on vend entre 6 et quand même
oui c'est parallèle move défaut ce
projet l'an patrice pour ce projet là et
on n'est pas obligé de faire
doubler la ligne verte du métro de faire
quelque chose en hauteur qui vont être
n'est pas mal excusez moi qui est chaud
pour le même prix avec des trains qui
vont passer à cinq mètres des frères de
radio-canada vaisseau
pour ça mais
quelque chose
de l'échappée atteint je me
reprendrai le le dédoublement c'est ça
qui coachait à un milliard le kilomètre
pour un métro on peut papoter prendre un
rêve qui va prendre la pinatelle du
métro et si elle prend la clientèle du
métro ça diminue les contributions à
l'air à la stm et l'oeil un modèle
économique qui fonctionne pas ça ne peut
pas marcher michel a raison faut arrêter
le rem de l'est à la station
honoré-beaugrand faut s'inscrire mais
pour l'heure été honorées bourgoin je
reçois la mairesse de montréal au
téléjournal de 18h j'ai hâte de lui
poser ces questions-là ce qu'elle se
contenterait d'une portion pointe au 31e
raymond grand pont fermé liv entre
martin politiquement sur le groupe si
les gens n'ont rien s'entendent pas il
veut se passe embarquer là dedans il ya
déjà le troisième ligne à gérer mais si
montréal où est le troisième levier mais
ça fait son pendant alors si si montréal
le veut cela mes restes de plantes le
veulent à ce projet là c'est maintenant
on est en année électorale c'est
maintenant qu'il faut qu'elle qu'ellen
s'arrange pour que monsieur legault
comète merci beaucoup à vous trois
intéressant parce que vous connaissez
le transport en commun beaucoup merci
beaucoup on se reparle très bientôt au
revoir lui construiront 18h30 on va
faire un on va reparler de toucher à
tous les genres merci ça pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh